i will also say that
i did a um a commercial parody on snl
called the love toya the love toilet
what's that it was two toilets that were
built together facing each other side by
side so that you could take a dump with
your loved one at the same time and look
at each other's eyes
it was very romantic and they swiveled
you know they shot around and um it was
very popular commercial i love that it
was good i love that did you love your
time on snl i did
i was on there as
i felt like i got really lucky being on
that show because i didn't do sketches
or characters or accents i was just a
stand-up a really really good stand-up
and
and um yes you were so every year i was
on there that i didn't get fired i
thought okay i'll stay another year you
know and and i i didn't see it as a
stepping stone for my career i saw it as
like a career move i'm just going to
stay there as long as it'll have me
yeah and but but it seems like the
hardest job in hollywood it really was
in new york but i mean it does seem like
the hardest job because
somebody once described comedy writing
like you have to come up with something
every week comedy writing is like when
they
when they ask you to your job is to [ __ ]
yeah but they don't feed you anything
right and you've got to take a [ __ ]
every day on an empty stomach yeah you
know maybe nothing funny is happening in
the news maybe nothing funny is coming
to your mind but you got a live show on
saturday and that's why you guys are
like on tuesday nights you're there
until three or four in the morning but
can you imagine how much material you
would come up with if you had to create
a 90-minute show every saturday
for yourself or even like a half hour
show not just material i couldn't do it
you would hire like 10 writers or
whatever and sit around and talk and
come up with tons of material so it was
easier than i'm saying it was breeze it
was a breeze no it wasn't the breeze no
it was for me i you know i i realized
that it wasn't a um a sprint in the
beginning it was a marathon so if a week
went by when i didn't come up with
something i didn't beat myself up but
what about coming up with something and
then sitting around we hear these these
stories about sitting around in the in
that room where you're pitching it yeah
to lauren you're pitching it to lauren
and the host for that week right
i i designed a strategy for that after
about three or four years
because you don't want to give your good
idea out there because if nobody likes
it it'll let the wind out of your sails
and you won't write it and it could be a
really good idea right or they'll
pooh-pooh it you know so i would go in
with the same pitch every day every
monday to the host the new host
and nobody realized that no they all
knew it they knew oh then okay kevin's
going to do his pitch now you know just
for the host and it was a pretty good
idea but i never wrote it up it was
called the runaway uh truck ramp you
know those runaway trucks they have in
case the brakes
they have like a gravel long road gravel
so the truck if your brakes fail
you go off into that lane and the gravel
the deep gravel will slow the truck down
enough until it finally comes to a stop
right
so that was my premise is i had a bar at
the end of a runaway truck ramp
so that the truck driver would come in
after this harrowing like stop and come
into the bar and buy drinks and start
drinking
i tell like
host that every week like this is i just
thought of this idea it's the craziest
idea because i didn't want to burn up
any of my ideas i didn't want any of the
other writers to you know hear it should
hear it or
but then but you also pitched other
ideas other ideas but nothing i didn't
pitch my good idea did it become funny
though after the umpteenth time of here
yeah i would mix it up a little bit
i was saying then these two clowns come
in you know
it's like a joke that has no punchline i
love you you know you just start adding
stuff but one particular um
pitch i remember the most was when
christopher walken was hosting
and across the street at radio see the
music hall they had the russian circus
there and they had
dancing bears
and so everyone's pitching to walk in
ideas and he's sitting there kind of you
know i'm not excited about any idea
really just kind of nodding his head
politely
and then um i said you know the russian
circus is uh next door radio city music
hall and they have bears you know they
have dancing bears and he goes
i love bath suits i love we could do
bath suits
and for some reason that was just a
trigger for him and he loved you know he
loved the idea it never got written up
but it didn't get rid of no we we did
the truck stop thing
two bears came in
i love that i love sitting around i have
to i have a kind of a similar story
where um
i did a daytime talk show which for me i
was on it you were on it which for me
though you being on it was a highlight
but it was really tough for me
and
we i wanted to do more comedy i didn't
want i wanted to talk to people like you
and i didn't want to do
uh makeovers and cooking segments and
everything that they force you to do and
supposedly daytime television is about
and i wanted to do more comedy and i
wanted the writers to come up with
things and we would write
but the executive producer who was hired
by the studio yeah wanted us to do more
of those other things so he was against
us doing more comedy goes listen if you
want to do comedy
then i'll sit in and i'll monitor the
comedy you're doing this is not a guy it
was a comedy guy
so i told the whole group of writers
that so and so is going to sit in and
we're going to to writing so he's never
even been in a writing room before and
we pitched [ __ ] that made no sense
and but we would laugh like somebody
would go
uh how about a bear and then the whole
room would go ah the bear we got to do a
bear and then somebody else for him to
go what if we give the bear a bell and
we would all laugh and you'd see the our
executive producer would be taking notes
and then he called me after the meeting
and goes i don't really i'll be honest
with you i don't get the bear with the
bell routine
and that went on for like weeks cop
bells i love car bells that's a good
walking i don't do compressions at all
[Music]